got like 200 people say ask him about  his real voice I'm like what does that  mean is that an inside joke nah it's  real  what they think your voice isn't real  what uh I really what the [ __ ]  that's not how you're really talking  that is my real voice I just talk like  this when I'm trying to like make music  and make content and [ __ ] but I really  talk like this in real life  get the [ __ ] out of here you connect  anybody that's how I really thought damn  I can't do that I can't read you at all  bro I usually I got people within the  first couple minutes but yeah  I know that's what everybody said  [Laughter]  you might be the greatest actor of all  time oh yeah  this whole time he's gonna come and take  his hair off like by the way guys  [Music]